today i'm going to talk about the
multi-legendary first learning is the
passive games from arthur gold to revise
control
since we know xi reinforced learning has
recently achieved tremendous empirical
successes and many great applications of
reinforced learning include say playing
game of go or playing video games or
even other control robotics therefore
actually there has been a resurgence of
interest in the theoretical
understanding of rl recently he will try
and understand why this rl method may
work
actually if you take a closer look at
many of the successful applications of
rl i mentioned most of them naturally
involve more than one decision makers
such as playing go games
also if you really want to deploy all
these r methods into practical like real
systems you have to take into
consideration the safety safety critical
concerns of this all these systems
therefore my research was trying to
develop prove our method that addresses
these concerns
and interestingly i'm going to show you
that this can actually be done under a
unified framework called stochastic
games or markov games created back in a
sharpie's working 50s
and a little bit prelude about the
results what we want to show is that
actually we started the fundamental
setting of markov games and in several
most popular reinforcement methods
including model-based approach and
model-free approaches
so the first part is going to talk about
model-based voltage in rl and we study
the sample efficiency of this method we
show that this method can actually be
nearly optimal
so let me first briefly introduce what
we mean by stochastic games actually it
is originally uh introduced by sharply
in his work in 50s we started a very
simple basic version it's called
two-player zero-sum classic games which
is characterized by this tuple whereas
is the set of states ai is action space
of player i and the and they are reward
ri
uh you know uh uh is affected by the
joint action of both agents and the
system state transitions following some
transition dynamics key which is also
affected by the drone action on both
stairs
and this model can actually be used to
model the goal games where you can view
like the placement or the positions of
the stones at the state
and every time you feel every round if
either of the players make a move it
corresponds to the action and it will
affect how the state transitions to the
next state
and also if you consider infinite client
setting you also also sometimes need to
have some discount factor on the long
term accumulator reward
so one key challenge in uh multi and rl
is
the issue called non-stationarity
because from one agent's perspective the
environment is changing while other
agents are adapting their policies
so one possible remedy for this is to
use some model-based approach where we
somehow have a bunch of data and then we
use the data to estimate some model like
the model of the games and then we do
any kind of
black box planning to try to find a good
policy all of this estimated model the
same model here what we missed mostly in
estimating the transition dynamics
dynamics p hat
and the fundamental question here is how
many samples are needed for this simple
plug-in method in this multi-general
setting
so our answer is that such a simple
method plug-in messenger can be nearly
min-max optimal
more specifically what we mean that this
model-based multi-general approach can
achieve this order of sample capacity if
you recall acids the candidality of the
state space a1 and a2 are the condition
of like action spaces of two players
gamma is a discounting factor an
absolute is the accuracy you want to
achieve
actually this kind of thermal convexity
also holds in finding the nash
equilibrium for multiple reward
functions or polynomial number of row
functions simultaneously
on the other hand we have the lower
bound of this complexity which depends
on the parameter of problem parameters
in this way where you have a1 plus a2
kind of dependence
this actually is kind of unique in the
multi-gene setting because if you are
considered a single engine setting
actually the a2 for example would be a
dummy a dummy a player and these two
bonds will match
however this kind of provides some
guidance for imperial studies in using
this model-based approach is that it has
some power because it can inherently
handle multiple rewards on multiple
tasks
however it is also has some limitation
in the sense that is less updated
adaptive and therefore it has to be
suboptimal in terms of the action space
dependence
the natural question arises is it
possible to reduce the complexity
which could be exponential in the number
of agents to the case where it might be
linear in the number of agents
so the model-based approach seems
hopeless although it is tight in some
other problem dependencies but it seems
not in terms of this action dependence
maybe we should resort to some model
free method to try to address this issue
so second part is about
how we use this method called
decentralized q learning to make to to
achieve this goal
so if you recall why is motivation are
challenging there are two key
challenging challenges here ones we call
non-stationarity because other agents
also learning simultaneously another
issue is a scalability issue especially
when there are a large number of agents
and you cannot coordinate other
so actually therefore the one natural
method is to run independent
uh
kind of reinforced learning
simultaneously for all the agents we
call it decentralized multitasking rl or
independent multi-scenario
however people have actually thought
about this idea back in dentist
there are some
non-convergence results
showing that if you naively apply all
the decentralized url method for all the
agents they will divert easily so can we
develop some symmetric and fully
decentralized multi-and aerodynamics
that prove a convergence
so before diving into details let's see
why this is this decentralized learning
is an important problem
actually if you consider many practical
multitasking learning scenarios they
involve some decentralized decision
making such as the control robots or the
urban traffic control problems
it is also very natural assumption in
economics we are modeling like the
rational decision makers
in practice the agents of myopic are
self-interested and sometimes they only
have local observation and often times
they are not even aware of the existence
of other agents or even not aware of the
structure of the game for example
whether the game is zero sum or not
also this decentralized learning address
is a scalability issue due to the large
number of agents
so another this is uh last one is some
something i think is kind of overlooked
by the recent studies on multigeneral is
that actually one justification of
equilibrium or nash equilibrium
specifically in static normal form games
is that it is a net arises as a natural
outcome of some myopic fast response
learning dynamics
however it is not clear whether this
story also holds in the stochastic
dynamic games
so what we show is actually we develop
some simple decentralized q learning
dynamics that prove it converges to nash
equilibrium for 2.0 some stochastic
games
so we develop some best response type of
learning dynamics whilst action of the
opponent cannot be observed
more specifically the algorithm consists
consists of two steps the first step is
that the player was trying to infer the
opponent's strategy by estimating
something called local queue function
so these steps look very similar to like
the queue learning or independent queue
learning but one caveat here is that we
are not updating here with the queue but
with some additional estimate of the
value function
i think in the second step the player
will estimate the value function
and then the player will take a soft
grading policy with respect with respect
to this local q estimate
and keep doing this and plug in the v
into the local pure update
so note that this dynamics is fully
decentralized it can be
implemented by each single agent
it's natural for self-interested players
it is symmetric and you don't need to
coordinate between agents
another feature of the dynamics is that
this this dynamics is two-time scale in
the sense that asymptotically the update
of the local q function is faster than
estimate of the local wave function
and the intuition here is that in that
case from the updating of the local
queue function it is as if you are
solving some auxiliary normal form game
with a fixed payoff matrix
also this update update rule for each
agent
he or she is oblivious to the presence
of the opponent and nor be aware of the
structure of the game this is something
called radically uncoupled is one of the
most challenging learning scenarios in
learning games
and then we show that this kind of
decentralized q learning converges to
nash equilibrium
and also we show that this learning
dynamics is also rational in the sense
that if the opponent is weak they are
adapting or adopting some stationary
strategy our learning dynamics can
convert the best response to that
finally let me wrap up by introducing
some the third approach where we develop
pulse operation methods for some of you
another kind of a fundamental class of
stochastic games
so most of the games i talk about like
in the tableau case the basic zero sums
or castle games the most basic games in
the continuous space is we call the
linear quadratic dynamics games more
specifically we know that the transition
of the states right now follows some
linear dynamics where the a1 a2 enters
the transition of the states in also in
a linear way and you can see here is the
random noise
and also at each stage the cost
has this quadratic form it is quadratic
with respect to system state and the
actions are both agents
and then if you
uh like what a practical people do you
can prime tracks your policy in a
certain way in this very standard and
the classical setting we know that you
can parametrize your policy in this
linear form without losing optimality
and then this actually give you gives
you a minimax optimization problem in
terms of the policy parameter knl
so while this is a interesting model
because this is actually a model that
unifies a robust control risk sensitive
control that
control people have studied for decades
more specifically in the robust control
setting you can view adversaries or
disturbances at the opponent that is
always trying to play against you
in the zero sum setting if you're trying
to solve this min max problem and then
you solve the inner loop maximization
problem to its optimal it is equivalent
to solve some robust control problem
with this
uh uh objective
and then if however if you do positive
search in this problem you can easily
show that this is a non-combat
non-concave mean max subtraction
optimization problem therefore motivated
by stabilizing the training of gas we
developed some double loop for two times
same kind of rule where you update the
inner loop from multiple steps for the
parameter of the opponent and then you
update the parameter of the controller
for multiple steps
however even in this case the landscape
of the outer loop objective which
corresponds to objective or robust
control is highly non-convex and
non-coercive in the sense if you compare
that on the right hand side with the
landscape of the optimal control problem
like linear quadratic regulator
the cost is not coercive
so it's very challenging to show like
how to enforce or regularize the
feasibility which in the robust control
setting correspond to the robustness of
the controller during policy learning
and interestingly what we can show is
that actually certain policy search
directions preserve the robustness of
the controller automatically something
called implicit realization it says that
this certain policy search directions
cannot regularize the
robustness of a controller during
learning even if you are using constant
step size
also we show that despite non-convex of
the problem certain policy search
directions will not get stuck at a
spirit local minimum and it will
converge globally to the global optimal
solution of this robust control problem
which corresponds to the nash
equilibrium of the linear quadratic game
which globally sublinearity and locally
superlinearity
so
this is the example of showing that if
you run naively run possibly method on
this robust control objective you can
easily get stuck at some
sub optimal local optimal
sorry some optimal stationary points if
you run the two methods like natural
policy within of course the other method
it can go directly to the global optimal
solution very fast
and lastly the most interesting is that
even if you view this policy search as a
computation method where as if you know
the model
it still can be much faster than many
existing robust control servers
which is usually based on linear
messaging quality
or solving like semi-definite
programming
so to conclude we started multigeneral
in the most fundamental setting zero
sums stochastic games with full
guarantees
so take care of the talk is that despite
being like less adaptive model-based
multi-general approach is nearly optimal
in terms of sample efficiency and it can
handle multi-tasks simultaneously
also despite the non-stationarity of
multi-general decentralized q-learning
can be made work if you have this kind
of two-time skills that step side
separation
finally despite the non-convexity pulsar
foundation can solve certain reverse
control problems as well as some linear
quadratic dynamic game problem with
global optimal guarantees and also it
preserves the robustness of the system
automatically something returned that's
increased requisition
and i'm really looking forward to more
discussions in the program if you're
interested in generally in the
intersection of learning game theory and
control theory thank you very much
question
have you looked into uh non-asymptotic
results
decentralized q-learning
yes that's something uh a way or
something about looking into right now
okay so we'll do our time so let's take
a break we assume again at 240 and
thanks to all the speakers